happening right now there is a  fundraiser for fallen metro police  detective justin terry he died nearly  two weeks ago in a road construction  accident near the centennial bowl the  injured police officers fund is holding  this cookout with food and merchandise  for sale  this is an opportunity for the family to  come out in the community to come out  and help support the family in a way  that is more than just monetary it is  showing that the community is a family  we are all here together to support one  and one another  the event is until three o'clock today  as you can see it's at the nevada coin  mart over at jones in flamingo all  proceeds go to detective terry's family  we have more information at 8 news now  dot com